SUPPORTERS INTO A MINDLESS RAGE.
JOINING US NOW IS A SECRET
SERVICE AGENT.
EVEN I, CYNICAL AS I AM, I AM
SURPRISED BY THE RESPONSE TO
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER.
WHICH I WAS SKEPTICAL IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
FOR PEOPLE WHO CALLED FOR THIS,
WHEN THEY GET IT TO IMMEDIATELY
ATTACK IT TELLS YOU SOMETHING
IMPORTANT.
>> IT DOES.
I DON'T KNOW WHY AMERICA IS
STILL PRETENDING WITH THE
RADICAL FAR LEFT, WE ARE DEALING
AT ALL WITH PRINCIPLED PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THE SAME THING ON
DETENTION OF MINERS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER HAPPENED WITH
OBAMA.
THE COVERAGE WAS NOWHERE NEAR
THIS.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH THESE GOONS
THEY DON'T GIVE A DAMN ABOUT
THESE KIDS.
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT ARE OPEN
VOTERS AND RAW VOTING POWER THEY
ARE LOSING TO WORKING CLASS
AMERICANS WHO REALIZE WHAT
LIBERALS REALLY ARE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRINCIPLES AT ALL.
>> I HAVE A BUNCH OF KIDS.
IF I GO TO JAIL AND I AM
SEPARATED FROM THEM EVEN IF I AM
CONVICTED, PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN PROVED GUILT SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN JAIL IN THIS COUNTRY,
WOULD A CABLE NEWS ANCHOR CRY
OVER THE FATE OF MY CHILDREN?
>> NO, YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE.
THEY WILL CELEBRATE THROWING YOU
IN JAIL.
THIS IS A POLITICAL PLAY FOR
THEM.
LIBERALISM IS DEAD.
IT'S A VACUUM.
THEY DON'T STAND FOR ANYTHING.
THEIR POLICY PLATFORMS ARE NOT
TENABLE.
THEY CAN'T PUT UP A CAMPAIGN
SIGN THAT SAYS GIVE US YOUR
MONEY AND HEALTH CARE AND LET US
TAKE OVER THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THEY HAVE TO REPLACE THOSE LOST
VOTES WITH FEAR AND REPLACING
THEM WITH OPEN BORDERS AND
ENDLESS PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY THEY CAN USE TO STEAL
THEIR VOTES THROUGH VOTER FRAUD
AND ENDLESS ENTITLEMENT